pourquoi les plantes sont vertes c'est
une bonne question pour y répondre il
faut d'abord savoir ce qu'est la lumière
c'est un phénomène naturel que l'on
perçoit grâce au sens de la vue et d'un
point de vue scientifique ce sont des
particules qui transportent les énergies
on les appelle les photons et toi tu
sais d'où elle vient la lumière elle
était mise par les étoiles comme le
soleil ou bien par les créations
humaines comme les ampoules ou les feux
de camp la lumière se propage dans le
vide à une vitesse de 300 mm par seconde
si on va la même vitesse ça voudrait
dire qu'on pourrait faire 7,5 fois le
tour de la terre en une seule seconde
c'est un truc de ouf non la lumière sert
aussi à émettre de l'énergie via les
panneaux solaires pour les humains et
via la photosynthèse pour les plantes
grâce à elle on voit aussi la couleur
bah oui la couleur n'est pas réelle
c'est notre cerveau qui l'a créé à
partir de la lumière je vous explique la
lumière entre dans notre œil et va au
niveau de la rétine c'est au fond de
l'oeil dans cette rétine il y a des
cônes et des bâtonnets ce sont des
cellules nerveuses la lumière vient les
stimuler les chatouiller si vous
préférez le message est ensuite transmis
en message électrique et va en direction
du cerveau c'est comme en texto le
cerveau réceptionne le message et le tra
duit en images colorée et voilà comment
la lumière se transforme en couleur en
tout cas dans l'œil humain la lumière ce
n'est pas qu'une couleur c'est aussi une
source d'énergie qui peut servir à une
drôle de cuisine
[Musique]
bien le bonjour les amis aujourd'hui
nous allons accueillir un grand chef
cuisinier avec ses quatre étoiles sur le
guide Michelin appelons Bernard bonjour
Laurent bonjour Bernard qu'allons-nous
préparer aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va
préparer une recette que j'affectionne
particulièrement et la Bretagne elle en
raffole c'est celle de la photosynthèse
mais commis aller chercher les
ingrédients s'il vous plaît oui chef
les amis je cherchais des minéraux pour
insta va chercher l'eau le CO2 et la
lumière ça me paraît
[Musique]
je suis fatigué j'ai ramassé l'eau la
lumière et le CO2
moi j'ai fait un Manu allez hop
[Musique]
dans un saladier prenez les minéraux
ajoutez de l'eau
versez le CO2
[Musique]
ajouter de la lumière
c'est sucré merci Bernard merci Laurent
c'est formidable on a fabriqué du sucre
et de l'oxygène l'oxygène se dégagera
dans l'air et le sucre la plante la
gardera pour se nourrir à vous d'essayer
mes petits chloroplastes dit la
chlorophylle ce serait pas comme un
panneau solaire oui un peu mais pas tout
à fait c'est plutôt une grosse molécule
qu'on retrouve dans les chloroplastes
a un super pouvoir car c'est elle qui
capte la lumière et fournit l'énergie
nécessaire à la photosynthèse elle
permet donc de transformer la matière
minérale en matière organique qu'elle
peut ensuite utiliser waouh la matière
minérale en matière vivante c'est en
effet un super pouvoir nous on n'a pas
le pouvoir de la fabriquer mais on peut
l'utiliser elle vous apporte de nombreux
bienfaits grâce à elle vous allez
notamment pouvoir purifier votre sang
elle permet aussi de stimuler votre
système immunitaire votre corps
résistera à tout après ça elle favorise
aussi la digestion
la chlorophylle rend les feuilles vertes
mais pourquoi en hiver elle ne le sont
plus quand la température baisse la
chlorophylle se dégrade donc les plantes
perdent de leur verdure les feuilles ne
peuvent donc plus capter à la lumière de
moins en moins forte l'hiver elle ne
peuvent plus faire la photosynthèse par
conséquent ne donne plus à manger à
l'arbre ceci fait que les feuilles
tombent des arbres en hiver
mais les armes ne meurent pas pour
autant ils s'endorment en attendant le
retour des beaux jours quand la lumière
revient au printemps la chlorophylle les
feuilles la faute synthèse
réapparaissent
il y en a qui ne perdent pas à leur fait
en hiver ce sont les animaux d'ailleurs
il y a plein d'animaux verts chez eux
cette couleur leur permet de se protéger
comme la tortue ce camoufler comme le
caméléon les effrayés comme le crocodile
ou les abuser comme le fasse mais il ne
faut pas de photosynthèse tout de même
il y a un animal vert qui fait de la
photosynthèse cela lui permet de se
nourrir ah oui c'est la limace de mer
alias elysiaque le rotica c'est une
volée ça c'est une imitatrice elle
ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau à une
feuille mais c'est-il qu'il existe aussi
des créatures fantastiques vertes non
jure comme l'effet les lutins et
martiens Hulk les Grinch bref le verrai
partout mais est-ce que tu sais que
c'est difficile à fabriquer le vert pour
obtenir du vert il faut mélanger des
pigments bleus et jaunes ce qui donne
des pigments verts ah ouais sacrément
dire à fabriquer un pigment est une
substance qui donne leur couleur externe
aux animaux ou aux plantes sais-tu qu'on
s'en sert par exemple pour en faire de
la peinture et d'ailleurs est-ce que tu
sais que certaines couleurs sont
extraits de plantes par par exemple
l'indigothier pour le bleu le coquelicot
pour le rouge et le yodande pour le
jaune donc on a vu qu'on avait du mal à
produire de la couleur verte mais la
nature s'en sort tellement bien qu'elle
produit elle-même sa couleur verte et
plein d'autres couleurs en fait la
couleur provient des différents pigments
dans une plante maintenant nous allons
voir les pigments responsables de la
couleur des plantes il y a les
chaoténoïdes c'est ce pigment qui est
responsable de la couleur jaune et
orange et son rôle principal c'est
d'être photoprotecteur de la plante
c'est-à-dire qu'il la protège les effets
négatifs de la lumière mais il n'y a pas
que ça comme pigment et heureusement il
y a les flavonoïdes qui sont
responsables de la couleur brune bleue
et rouge des plantes et des fruits mais
surtout ce pigments protège des
bactéries des virus et des moisissures
donc toutes les plantes contiennent de
la chlorophylle c'est pour ça que la
grande majorité des plantes sont vertes
mais cette couleur est parfois masquée
par des pigments secondaires comme les
flavonoïdes ou les caroténoïdes donc en
gros la couleur d'une plante résulte de
l'interaction entre ces différents
pigments voilà pourquoi les plantes ne
sont pas toutes vertes si toutes les
plantes sont vertes est-ce qu'il y a pas
un endroit où on trouve pas de plantes
vertes on a regardé en fonction des
différents types de sol et à l'acidité
du sol il existe plusieurs types de sol
comme le sol sableux sur ce sol on peut
planter par exemple du romarin des
agapanthes des tulipes et des cosmos le
sol peut être aussi argileux et dans ce
cas on peut planter plusieurs variétés
de pain de bouleau de charme
si le sol est hummifère on peut trouver
les orties c'est de la merde des
fougères ainsi que du genêt enfin il
existe un dernier type de sol sans
blague c'est le seul limoneux où on peut
cueillir différents fruits comme le
pommier le cassissier et en légumes le
melon la tomate et la salade
mais il y a aussi le pH qui est
important il peut être acide sur ce sol
on peut planter du camélia de l'azalée
et de la myrtille le pH peut être aussi
neutre on peut alors planter de la
groseille blanche de la pivoine ainsi
que de la rose trémière enfin le pH peut
être basique on peut y faire pousser de
l'ail
à tête en fait on peut trouver des
plantes vertes partout et le type de sol
et le pH n'ont rien à voir avec la
couleur verte merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que ça t'aura plu
et c'est réalisé par les élèves de
seconde à la méfère de Saint-Grégoire
[Musique]
le commis tu es censé arriver
de la lumière tu peux moins
d'enthousiasme encore
la lumière nécessaire à la photosynthèse
c'est pas ça j'ai oublié un bout
elle ne peut pas elle ne ouais elle ne
peut plus
mon Dieu de pesant là cette couleur là
leur permet de se protéger
pourquoi tu as mangé sur comme le je ne
sais plus un prénom le crocodile moi je
dis juste ça moi
je balance tout
ah parce qu'on voit tout seul
si toutes les plantes
et le type de sol et le pH n'ont rien à
voir
et Daphné il faut que tu sois là
en fait la couleur provient
ah si en plus c'était ça
ressemble à deux gouttes d'eau
on a regardé en fonction des
[Rires]
on a regardé non bah non pas si
j'ai besoin de le dire ça énerve
énormément